hello and welcome to the lobby game
spots weekly hangout every tuesday at
2pm pacific right here on videogames.com
iron thompson how you doing how are you
doing i'm doing real good sometimes i
say videogames.com because i remember
that we own videogames.com also nuke.com
for some reason we used to have that
years ago nuke.com encounter spot right
we own kanyespot.com that redirects to a
very specific part of america.com i
believe uh how you doing mike marty good
how are you great you've i've i'm doing
all right you've been playing a lot of
video games for the past couple weeks uh
most of which we are talking about on
today's show as that happens uh we're
going to talk about sort of the reaction
to battlefield 1 and infinite warfare in
a little bit uh we're also going to talk
about overwatch and battleborn a lot of
people i mean it's pretty self-apparent
to people actually played these games
but a lot of people have been asking
sort of what's the difference between
these two games having not played them
so we'll just do a little bit of a q a
on that um we're also going to talk
about the witcher 3 blood and wine jake
decker is going to come in and tell us
all about his time playing that uh and
also
10 out of 10 on charter four yeah
gamespots.com it is out today on
playstation 4. it has all of the charts
it's got all of them we are no longer
the photographers can put down their
pens we have charted everything
uncharted is done uh you really liked it
yeah it was
it's a really really great game i come
to talk about it okay we'll talk about
later on no spoilers as well but first
of all actually i want to sort of get to
a little bit of breaking news that just
happened right before we came online uh
there's an update here on
uh the disney interactive blog from a
one john blackburn who is the senior
vice president and gm of disney infinity
uh to quote him he says by now you may
have already heard the news that we have
made the difficult decision to
discontinue
production of disney infinity from the
beginning disney infinity was built for
you our fans and wanted to take a moment
to thank you not just for your support
over the years but for creating a
community that made disney infinity more
than just a game our goal for disney
infinity was to bring the best of disney
story italian to life in homes around
the world with your support we
accomplished that we hope uh that you
have as much playing in the game as we
had making it so what's next for disney
infinity we have two final retail
releases coming including three new
characters from alistair looking glass
later this month and from finding dory
uh the playset that's the new movie
pixar releasing uh in a couple of weeks
um
playset launching in june and as we turn
to the next chapter in our story i want
to thank everyone who helped bring
disney infinity to life particularly
disney's glendale based production and
publishing teams our external
development partners and of course the
incredible avalanche team for the
tireless dedication to this project but
most of all i want to thank you again
for making disney affinity a part of our
lives and for making uh for adding to
the disney legacy by being part of this
community i'm a little shocked i thought
these games were selling well i thought
they bought star wars and we're going to
milk it in every possible way right i
mean i played 3.0 i hadn't played any of
the other ones um
i played 3.0 and i actually really
enjoyed it uh for what it was you you're
a father of children though aaron you
tell me
because for me i was like i was almost
taken aback by how playable i mean it
wasn't like the most magnificent 3d
platform ever made but there was kind of
enough substance there to make an
enjoyable play uh but i kind of didn't
really figure i couldn't figure out what
age group it was for yeah i definitely
like i experiment with games with my
kids and
like they like sitting in my lap and
watching me play destiny for some reason
and i through disney i threw disney
infinity at them um
one of the more recent star wars updates
uh and i gotta say like for at least the
five year olds it was still a little bit
too complicated right um like the ewok
village had some really complex puzzle
platforming and the combat was actually
pretty robust with like combo attacks
and things like that so it depends like
i think maybe a seven-year-old could
have really related to disney infinity
for kids younger than that it was still
a little bit too challenging
although i will say they did enjoy
ripping the arms off of
like the ahsoka tano
statue that i had i mean that's the
other part of it as well is that this
whole toys to life thing
we've very much gotten the impression i
think as consumers that it must be doing
really well i mean amiibos are we've got
a couple of amiibo addicts here in the
office um and then the same with uh
skylanders as well like they they seem
to be like whenever i go to a friend's
house and they've got kids and they got
a game console they tend to either have
some infinity or skylanders stuff
apparently that wasn't enough for them
either i mean ultimately the business
model for any toy seller is to get it
the parents wallets through their kid
you got to get the kid to ask the parent
for the toy
and that's when parents usually say yes
right because parents aren't gonna for
the most part go buy this stuff on their
own so to me that says that they didn't
connect with the kids somehow
because they're they're the target
market like i guess
when you think about one of the big
disney games that have come out in the
past couple of years like i don't know
if there was a frozen
playlist or a playset on this maybe
there was maybe there wasn't i mean
you're talking about monsters inc and
incredibles and stuff like that which
are kind of a couple of years old now
and a couple of years in child's toys is
like a lifetime right yeah um so maybe
the star wars i don't know it just seems
crazy that they're literally tanking
this entire project yeah based off of
what apparently is low sale like
i don't know you thought disney were
flush at the moment yeah it was a few
years ago uh right before disney
infinity came out when i was i sat down
to play it at gdc and i remember
thinking and this was before they even
had like star wars so i was thinking
okay disney plus like toys like
skylanders by this point had proven to
be really lucrative and they were only
on like their second game everything
yeah that was originally a spyro
spin-off so it was essentially that was
a pitch take skylanders at it to disney
and then you can sell the models which
like even from a collector's standpoint
that seems like it could be lucrative
but also like they're well-made toys
i've bought like five or six of those
model sets in the
to my shame yeah and they're sitting
like only because i'm like i'm a fan of
up and i'm a fan of like inside out so i
like i have and they're like they were
relatively inexpensive actually as well
was the other thing in the sets but yeah
still like you think disney fans would
buy anything that seems like the perfect
storm of everything a kid or like a lot
of adults would like especially with the
collector's mindset the fact that if
you're into games you can like them and
then if it coalesces with your interest
in toys that's just a perfect
combination i'm very surprised as well
that that's it wasn't going as well as i
thought yeah i will say that my kids
have surprised me um
some of this might and this is just my
speculation but some of this might be
because a lot of kids these days will
watch other kids play with toys on
youtube right rather than play with toys
themselves much in the same way how like
our generation's baffled when people
watch gamers play games on youtube
rather than just you know back in my day
we played the games ourselves yeah you
know i had a friend of our family um uh
sorry our vendor family's sons stay over
in our place over the weekend um for his
like 14th birthday and i was at like he
i gave him like four out of four to play
some fallout 4 and he played it for
about 30 minutes and actually this is
more fun to watch yeah
so yeah it's too complicated for him
there's that weird trend these days
where like kids and even young adults
get on youtube and they just sort of
cathartically watch other people do it
rather than do it themselves yeah i
wonder if the toy market it's like
adults and porn yeah
disney infinity has marvel too i can't
believe that
like i keep forgetting how many like how
much they have on like in their court
for that now i want to know how
skylanders are doing
i can't
i mean i know that was the precursor to
that whole like sub genre but i can't
imagine they're doing really well if
marvel and disney and pixar are not
selling these toys in these games weird
very strange uh i guess
you know all we can say is uh
sort of our thoughts go out to everyone
who worked on production for disney
infinity um i hope you guys land on your
feet and yeah he made a really great
game regardless of of what happened to
it um best of luck and yeah hopefully
we'll hear more about this over the next
um days and uh and weeks as people start
to sort of comment and flesh out this
story uh interesting though that's just
breaking uh just as we went live but
we've got a bunch of other games to talk
about
uh first things first
you got your thumbs
i got phones in both directions
warm up your thumbs got that thumb
warning
um yeah battlefield one has the highest
thumbed up trailer uh
in the history of youtube trailer yeah
in the history of youtube um arm pointed
this out a couple days ago and also call
of duty on the opposite side yep but
it's it's one of the most thumbed down i
think game trailers so this can come
from like a variety of places also it's
like perfect like clip click base for a
video game websites new story you know i
mean like it sounds great uh but let's
kind of talk about the reaction to both
of these games sort of outside of that a
little bit um first of all let's talk
about battlefield one we did a sort of a
breakdown after that announcement you
went down and saw some awesome gameplay
stuff we've already talked about that
you can check it out on youtube and
gamespot um but the reaction to that
trailer were you surprised at all aaron
about how
uh refreshing or how intuitive people
were considering it is you know it's a
it's a war we've not really seen much of
yeah i think world war one hasn't been
done
all that well at least in american
cinema and i was doing a lot of research
after that came out i noticed there were
quite a few british movies which makes
sense
um
and i think it also hasn't been that
explored in video games just because of
probably the misconception that the
weapons would be fairly boring yes um
so yeah i gotta say that it caught me
off guard i thought maybe they were
gonna go back to world war ii or maybe
do korea or vietnam
uh it's was surprising in a very good
way just because now i'm excited like
it's a campaign about a war that i don't
honestly know a lot about right um
and that's exciting it means that i you
have an opportunity to not only enjoy
yourself from a shooter perspective but
also
you know learn something or had or
experienced something that maybe you
only ever saw in black and white history
class films or
you know to me that's exciting yeah and
that is new it's weird that you say that
actually because when i think about
playing the original call of duty and
like i remember feeling like really
upset at the the when you like stormed
the reichstag and bring up like the
soviet flag and stuff like it's quite an
effect like for me as a teenager as a
young sort of teenage boy like that was
how i learned a lot about world war ii
in the same way like band of brothers
was a and like saving private ryan like
taught an entire generation what
happened on the normandy beaches who
might have known otherwise um do you
think there's anything to be said about
that that like people have this sort of
emotional reaction to something when it
has actually happened and existed in a
way that they don't when we started
going to the world of like sci-fi yeah
for sure i mean when i was i was pretty
young when the first call of duty came
out and i remember my dad whose dad was
in uh the pacific theatre during world
war ii was actually pretty uncomfortable
with me playing with two games yeah
because i hit close to helm with him and
now i have a brother who's done
three tours in iraq and two in
afghanistan he's completely fine playing
like battlefield 4 modern warfare 3 or
whatever um and i think it could hit
closer to home and that's why world war
one itself i'm really excited for the
multiplayer i'm actually pretty excited
for i've i've
read about and like i actually took like
a class on world war one and it was
because i didn't know much about it all
right
i actually the more i think about the
single player it's a cool opportunity to
kind of shed light on it and i'm hoping
they don't
video games play a huge part i'm not
saying i don't like organs i play a lot
of work games play a lot of shooters but
video games in the modern day play a
huge part in how we kind of romanticize
war still right and like with so many
people playing games now and i'm hoping
maybe with this game they'll take the
opportunity to kind of
show how
world war one itself was like no one
knew why this is this is the war when we
realized we need to stop doing this and
like yeah because world war ii was very
much more black and white you know good
versus evil world war one there were so
many different reasons like sinking to
lutania there was the rc ferdinand
assassination there was the fact that
germany had the plan of attack the
schlieffen plan whatever they called it
in like planned out decades in advance
before world war one and uh i'm
interested to see if they can actually
use this setting to kind of push a good
story and but good story as in you know
like not to make use of
all the [ __ ] that went down but yeah
maybe kind of shed more light on it
because a lot of people don't know about
what we're one now it's overshadowed by
world war ii in terms of you know like
like i said like how almost romantic it
was yeah i mean yeah world war ii sort
of has
cult culturally its impact i mean we
just had another star wars movie and
that's basically an allegory for world
war ii um yeah it's fascinating to think
that you know these are
you're right like film for years cinema
was what sort of emblazoned the cultural
impression of what we like you think
about vietnam and apocalypse now and and
other movies like that like you know
full metal jacket and stuff and that's
how we sort of remember these things and
video games have dotted in and out and
i mean
i sort of always felt uncomfortable
playing some of the call of duty games
set in
uh in the middle east yeah because i
thought that there was a sort of an
attempt to create the same black and
white uh sort of
idea we had of like other old wars the
way we think about old wars and those
sort of productive terms in a place
where that really doesn't necessarily
apply um did you ever guys feel that way
about some of the more modern sort of
call of duty games and maybe more
particular actually the medal of honor
game that came out
a war fighter yeah yeah yeah i i
remember i was actually playing that
while my brother was in iraq or
something so that was and you know
as well so
i was in the air force therefore sorry
yeah i don't remember specifics about
warfighter i remember being definitely
kind of doing that though making it more
of a us versus them mentality for what i
mean
from what i played i don't know
i've had more issues with some of the
way film has portrayed right modern work
i think it's been
too much like
you know rago america everybody's evil
um
and it's sort of undercut the complexity
of the middle east and to bring that
back around the complexity of the middle
east although that area of the world's
always been complex a lot of the modern
complexity comes from the fall of the
ottoman empire right world war one so
going back to battlefield one like you
have an opportunity to explore sort of
the creation of the modern day
situations
like a lot of the borders on the map in
the middle east right now we're just
drawn by some people
after at the end of world war one
they're just like yep here's a pen that
looks good let's put a line here and
they just they grouped together peoples
who had no business being grouped
together i mean you say ottoman empire
to most people they think of something
that existed like centuries ago not less
than a century ago
um and that's why people are always
saying there's like these what-if
scenarios if the nazis won world war ii
but if you look back our world today
exists so much because of world war one
europe would be unrecognizable if we
like were to look at some other timeline
where you know the austrians took italy
or you know the germans actually pushed
into paris like they they almost very
closely did but screwed it up because
someone made a bad decision from a
strategic standpoint but yeah that's the
setting itself i'm actually the more i
think about it the more i'm excited for
the single player because
a the single player they said there's
gonna be more like multiplayer in the
sandbox structure yeah which i'm hoping
they actually really go for that and
it's not just a selling point but i'm
also really hoping they can tell the
stories like the harlem health fighters
that'd be a really really cool group to
look at and see
how like it affected them and how they
kind of were this un undersold story
during world war one i'm excited for
that setting for sure all right let's
shift perspectives then from the past to
the future uh call of duty infinite
warfare obviously got to jump on them by
about a week or so i think um
the trailer has had some thumbs down
probably a lot of those have to do with
the call of duty four pack in deal that
they're doing i mean that's that's gonna
happen i guess um but
do you think maybe people are
because i was intrigued by infinite
warfare i was at least thinking oh at
least they're trying something new at
least they're not like resting entirely
on another you know slightly near future
oh look this is the same gun you're
using now but now it has a different
magic future scope on it or whatever uh
i'm like thrusting it into a new sort of
plane and hopefully like you were saying
aaron actually making good on in terms
of gameplay and not just like having it
be a story setting and basically be a
normal uh first-person game uh
battlefield
when you put the two of them together
now it looks like bathroom is so much
more intriguing but what do you think
about um call of duty infinite warfare
and are you sort of do you think it's a
step in the right direction for
for activision and infinity ward or do
you think it's not enough or or are we
just being jerks because all we've ever
obviously seen is two trailers and at
least they showed gameplay kind of i
think it's a game that's
become a little bit trapped by its own
success
um i think they've been not straying too
far from their own formula just because
that's what sells and they probably are
have been given
marching orders to not change it too
much um that's why i'm a little bit
worried that this one
will just be on like it'll be another
planet sure but it's just
functionally going to be the same thing
now
i think it's pretty cool that it it's
got a million thumbs down because to me
if i were making this game i would go to
my bosses and be like look this is a
mandate
from gamers to change like we we should
try some new things check out how many
people don't like the fact that this
appears to be the same game
i think it's a positive thing and i
think if anything it could free them
from having to do the same thing every
year
now i think you disagreed and said and
it's probably the truth it'll just
depend on sales right
if it's if everybody thumbs it down and
it sells the same then sure they'll just
make another future future warfare right
next year
like
i mean i don't know how there's nothing
beyond infinity but so they kind of put
themselves in a corner there yeah it's
it's it's i think you're right it's like
it's the success is a doublehead storage
as we sort of talked about a bit last
week and how do you really innovate a
series which is selling so well even if
it is like dipping a little bit um like
looking ahead to the future even more
you gotta say that if battlefield one is
what we're talking about now then the
chances are the next next battlefield is
probably going to stay around that
period of time you'd imagine like oh
that's the perfect opportunity for them
to roll back into world war ii
and not instantly be stuck like i wonder
it's sad to be talking about what
they're going to do next after these but
i wonder if i guess it'll all happen on
the success of this whether or not
there's enough like gameplay change to
to make it worthwhile mike what do you
think of infinite warfare yeah i'm
really hoping because i mean i think in
the way they revealed the game is
actually kind of telling i mean it seems
like dice and ea showed us a lot more of
battlefield 1 than
activision infinity war did like in
terms of gameplay at least i saw more
gameplay i'm i well you saw more games i
think their trailer was
twice as long as what the public saw
right right sure um and i think
i don't know i'm hoping it's not just
like a futuristic skin i'm hoping they
actually make like make use of it
because i don't know it'd be cool that i
don't know this is spitballing what if
you had a multiplayer map that you're
you're warping between different parts
that had like different time travel
differently there's different gravity in
different areas because there's ant
there's zero grav combat according to
the trailer and they're showing it but
how much is it how much of that is just
going to be what was at the beginning of
ghost where you're floating and shooting
people just like you are in call of duty
i want them to actually use the setting
to kind of propel
what they're doing forward rather than
just make the game and then throw a
futuristic paint on it and just say you
know like what you said this is what an
ak-47 would look like in 50 years or
something i don't want that i want i
want them to actually kind of tell a
story or use like do new cool new things
with multiplayer they couldn't do like
in black ops 3 like because the wall
running was just you know like from
remind me of titanfall and then the
shooting reminded me of every other call
of duty game i want them to actually
take the step that they're purporting to
be with this trailer i'm hoping it's
actually futuristic and not just paint
it to look like it i mean the other
thing as well is that like you can have
a temporary a contemporary war
game be really good and evocative like
call of duty modern warfare was called
d4 modern warfare you just have to have
like a very well-written game with like
interesting set pieces and i feel like
we've had that in like black ops one for
instance i thought i had that and i
think the two modern warfare games did
personally i haven't really connected
with any like advanced warfare any of
those they were sort of like fun little
diversions like an action movie is but
like i still look up i still remember so
much of call of duty 4. um
and
you know maybe it's just a case of
we look at these games at this really
superficial level and actually when we
get to play them you know that's that
that's the time for these studios to be
able to deliver what they're actually
trying to do and you know maybe we judge
maybe we judge this game too early
because we expect it to do so little
sure but then they've also been doing
that for a couple of years although if
anything they've set themselves up in an
environment where they could do amazing
things
again like mike said with gravity like
give us the first multiplayer map set on
a spherical asteroid where i throw a
grenade and hit myself on the back of
the head if i'm not careful you know
or like again give me a space battleship
where the the multiplayer combat takes
place both inside and outside of the
ship right yeah i mean there's things
that again going back there's things
that battlefront
um did a long time ago that we haven't
seen since and we haven't seen done
better and in this level of detail so
you know again if you're just gonna have
the future ak-47 and a flat map
with
earth's gravity space people yeah like
then you really haven't innovated at all
yeah i guess we'll have to wait and find
out um
yeah i mean i'm excited for the two of
them i i'm haven't been excited for call
dude in a in a little while i feel and i
am actually excited about this one
battlefield one obviously just the the
sort of
anticipation of what that could be is is
obviously uh very tantalizing as well
mike what about yourself what are you
sort of looking forward to and if you
put these two games side by side i am
looking forward to both of them as well
um i think more so battlefield one just
because mainly because
that series hasn't been where i want it
to be for a long time so i think every
time it comes out or they show it off
i'm hoping it'll get back to what i
loved about battlefield these you know
these prolonged more
multiplayer matches with more substance
because call of duty's become this
twitch gameplay which i actually i like
um it reminds me of like you know not in
the same way that counter-strike did but
i love counter-strike because there's a
very specific kind of shooter and i love
overwatch because it's pulling from a
lot of them but i'm hoping that
battlefield one does add more substance
to like returns they say the return to
their roots i hope they return to the
right parts and infinite warfare i'm
curious about but battlefield 1 is the
one that kind of got me like really
excited yeah uh aaron you're a big fan
of battlefield you've covered
battlefield games here at gamespot all
the time uh what are you looking forward
to added to these
uh battlefield one takes place at a
point in history where a lot of warfare
was not figured out
and i think that's an exciting setting
you know like i said they started with
airplanes where they were just spotting
and then you know some bag of dicks
brought a shotgun with them and then
another guy brought a shotgun then
another guy brought a machine gun and
next thing you know you've got aerial
duels you know they invented a tank it
drove at three miles per hour
so you could just step out of the way if
you really wanted to and they just
invented it to take on machine guns
right they didn't really know how to use
it i think
that's exciting it's exciting to set a
game at a point in history where
it's not like future ak-47 it's
we don't know what an ak-47 is but let's
try making a rifle semi-automatic and
see what happens yeah so that to me is a
fun setting and still allows for a lot
of the weapon customization that they'll
sneak it in
that they have in battlefield already
all right well in any case it looks like
we're getting two interesting looking
military first-person shooters this year
uh let us know though what you think
what are you most looking forward to
call of duty infinite warfare or
battlefield one put your thoughts in the
comments below uh our good friends in
the twitch chat have all been screaming
at me for call of duty disney infinity
warfare um to maybe
solve those two problems at the same
time um maybe not probably not maybe
that's what happened they're just going
to kill off actually
they lost the disney they bought disney
it's all over yeah infograms bought
ubisoft and then bought disney and then
bought activision and they're going to
merge it all together or downforce
syndicated yeah rayman in your in your
call of duty video game uh all right
let's talk about some more first-person
games
we have no shortage of first-person
video games first-person military games
have been around for donkeys years uh
this year we got two very colorful
first-person games
in fact one of them's out already got
seven out of ten on game spot another
one out in a couple of weeks uh march
tour sorry march may 24th two weeks from
now i believe and i think you're
reviewing that one are you correct yeah
all right so you're being overwatch
battleborn's already out
the beta for overwatch closed earlier
today uh battleborn is still alive and
kicking bunches of people playing it
online at the moment um but one of the
sort of weird questions we keep getting
even though people have had access to
both games now in some sort of form is
like what's the fundamental difference
between these two games and i think that
was a big problem years ago when we had
battleborn and battle cry and bloodborne
all coming out at the same time like
that name got confusing yeah um and then
overwatch obviously came out and people
were like oh it's another first person
moba what's going on what's going on
what's going on so we said we do a short
video sort of just explaining what the
two games are because they are actually
very very different um aaron first of
all you've played a lot of battleborn
over the past couple of weeks um if you
would explain like in a nutshell like
elevator pitch style what is battleborn
uh battleborn is a
the best way to describe it is it's a
not borderland sequel okay it's it's not
borderlands um but it has the same feel
of borderlands the same sort of status
effects and shooting and like
weightlessness you take the shooting
formula from
uh borderlands
you instead of unlocking guns you're
unlocking people
who have abilities and it has an
extensive single-player campaign as well
as the sort of moba-esque
multiplayer
um and
you're playing both just to get your
characters unlocked and you're are you
primarily playing with other people then
like sort of borderlands you could go
either way i played solo most of the
time but most people seem to enjoy
pairing off what's been your experience
with in terms of polyform with that you
have to play with other people oh yeah
um you can do the campaign by yourself
but it's not recommended a lot of the
challenges you'll find very difficult
particularly if you pick a support class
character
and it's just more fun with friends it's
one of those games where i think your
friends are the best part of it you're
right um the characters themselves i
like i i gotta say they put a lot of
love into the characters of of
battleborn
they really like they're hilarious they
say really funny stuff while you're
fighting with them they feel like
they all have backstories and
personality and they react to the
environment differently and even in
multiplayer they will call things out
that surprised me like
hey there's that sniper guy again or
like so you're supposed to run away from
the bullets or like
one of the guys i died real quickly and
he's like so this is our first match
you know they like their personalities
shine through and i think that's my
favorite part of the game
cool uh on the other side of us mike a
bunch of us have been playing overwatch
in in the office at the moment um sort
of taking that as your starting point
that this is a sort of a very
team-based
team co-op sort of experience in the
vein of a you know floaty weightless um
uh
not battle um
give me the word give me the word
borderlands borderlands game thank you
um what is what would you explain
overwatch to somebody who sort of
already knows what battleborn is sure so
overwatch is more of a
class-based multiplayer shooter
competitive i know like a lot of people
thought it might be more of a moba when
it first came out because there is a
incursion mode in battleform battleborn
is very much mobile they're minions and
you're taking you're destroying these
towers or you're strong these robots are
essentially like the the towers and
whatnot before you get to the fortress
um overwatch is more of uh i don't know
like it's if you took team fortress
which had nine classes i think
and just put made 21 different classes
and made them all crazy and really
in-depth characters uh it's more
it borrows from like shooters styles
from different shooter games right so
you have diva who's got this tank she
can get into it's like titanfall then
you have
um you have pharah the airborne
rocketeer who's kind of like a quake
character it's it's very much like uh
taking the best of different shooter
genres and pitting them against each
other in this more fast very fast pace
uh the objectives are there but they're
almost more to facilitate just the
fighting between these really crazy
characters right so battleborn sort of
has more all-encompassing scenarios in
terms of like objectives right you've
got your single-player
single-player modes presumably have like
relatively
mediumly complex objectives and the
multiplayer sort of has a lot of wheels
uh sort of spinning at the same time
yeah the single player also has a story
which is a pretty big difference from
overwatch which is just purely
a shoot multiplayer competitive shooter
so i mean probably the biggest
difference between the two is just that
battleborn does have a story mode i i
can't remember exactly how long it is
but it's pretty meaty each mission is
about
can be up to like 30 to 40 minutes
depending on how you play them oh is
that like so like a standard online game
as well in in battleborn would that be
around that time as well you're talking
like they're a little bit length almost
yeah they're a little bit longer than i
expected actually the multi-player
matches they can i don't know it depends
what you like
and people who like that john will
probably enjoy it i found that they ran
a little bit longer than i wanted
but also there's a lot to do other than
just kill other people there's there's
the whole upgrade tree that you go
through every match a lot of that has to
do with you
farming minions and preventing minions
in certain modes like i think incursion
from
they're the things that actually win the
match
so it's got
it's got some really fun aspects that
don't involve you just fighting other
people like you can bait other people
away from the minions so that you get
the points
or you can suicide into a pack of enemy
minions it doesn't matter if you die
your kd doesn't matter what matters that
you stop the minions and i like the fact
that it's not just purely focused on kd
and killing other players there's
actually there's actual strategy to it
and in that regard it's it's a lot of
fun actually so they you're saying like
lengths of the the maps there around the
sort of 40 minute mark and then you also
have this um in
level or in mission um leveling system
where you're sort of dinging your
character there level four and then you
open up this skill tree again sort of
like a moba in terms of either leveling
or in terms of you know acquiring new
abilities you know via a shop or via you
know upgrading yourself because of the
levels um on the other side of a mic
that stuff doesn't exist in overwatch
right the matches are much shorter right
yeah the matches i think the quickest
i've done is probably i mean if you're
playing on a on a good team against a
bad team it could be like four minutes
five minutes but the longest i've seen
is probably
just above 15 if that even 10
right because 15 is pretty long um and
it's all you know you get the attack and
defend objectives where you're taking
point a and then the defense is kind of
falling back to defend point b and then
the attackers win if you do that then
you're escorting these payloads which
kind of you know there are classes kind
of they're the tank characters that
function better to absorb damage and
kind of push an objective offensive
characters defensive characters support
like healers and shielders um but yeah
they're not each match within each match
they're static aside from gaining it all
and kind of using that which their most
powerful attack uh battle born you're
actually using that helix system to gain
new abilities as you go and you have the
loadout system with the items which is a
very mobile thing too it's streamlined
in battleborn but in overwatch you're
just it's your character and their
abilities yeah they're free abilities or
maybe you know some of them have got
more obviously which which sounds it's
deceivingly
simple deceivingly it seems simple but
it's it becomes complex and how
different characters interact with each
other how different characters can buff
each other or counter each other if
you're on the other team how different
characters can play both offense and
defense it's very it becomes very
nuanced the more you play
i don't even know how many hours i've
played now with the beta and the early
access but at this point i'm still
playing new characters i like barely
touched before and it's it's kind of
forcing you to realize how all these
layers interact and it's yeah it's
it's a fun game cool well that's a sort
of uh top level overlook at those two
games over watching battleborn obviously
so much of what you enjoy from a first
person shooter comes from just how it
feels and and and how accustomed you are
to that in terms of the sort of first
person games you usually play um aaron
yourself which one is sort of feels
better for you which one are you
enjoying the most out of two
it's funny but i'm actually starting to
trend towards overwatch just as a
cleaner experience
um battleborn as much as i love the
characters i've had a couple of rounds
where when especially when i was a melee
character it devolved into wading into
large groups of people smashing the
attack button with the screen being so
full of status effects and like just
people's bodies and like random butts
flying by that like the only thing you
can tell is if you're in the scrum or
out of the scrum right and other than
that you're just staring at your meters
and and mashing the attack button
whereas overwatch
in many ways seems to be just a more
cleanly focused title
um but again if you're a single player
person and you like the characters um
and you like the personality of the
characters then i think battleborn is
more your style what about yourself mike
um i prefer overwatch at this point for
sure i'll be playing battleborn in the
weeks leading up to overwatch's launch
and official launch and 24th but yeah
overwatch is just kind of scratching
that edge for
these characters are easy to learn
really easy to learn each one of them
even if you don't like once you grasp
the controls you'll be able to figure it
out the ui is pretty good but like still
i'm still mastering some of my main
characters or trying to i don't know if
mastering's the right word that's
selling myself too high but uh yeah
overwatch is the one that's i i'm
thinking it might be one of my go-to
games throughout the year right yeah
yeah i kind of feel the same way i i
actually sort of feel a little bit sorry
for when battleborn has come out i feel
like this was a game i wish came out
back in january or something where there
wasn't that much to play uh because i
did i enjoyed it more than i thought i
would because i'm probably not the best
person to try and sell battleborn to
because i wasn't a massive fan of
borderlands um for whatever reason the
way that game shoot the shooting works
with the you know numbers popping off
and stuff it's probably similar to the
reason i've never got really that much
into the division either or destiny to
that effect so i don't think i'm exactly
the person they should be marketing that
game towards anyway but i did actually
really enjoy is the incursion mode
that's what it's called right um in
battleborn i thought that that was a
unique
uh sort of that was an enjoyable way of
doing that there was enough happening on
screen where it wasn't like the single
player stuff where it was super crazy
and it almost felt like objectiveless
because there was so much going on
um whereas it felt more easy to control
than something like paragon which i
played a little bit the week previous
which
something about the camera didn't feel
right in terms of like trying to do
these ranged and aoe attacks i thought
battleborn did a way better version of
that um but yeah it's kind of a weird
little crisis they have where where
they're coming out alongside something
which although very very different and
obviously doesn't have some of the stuff
you're talking about the single player
um some of the core functionality of
that game uh or at least just in terms
of being a first-person game you play on
the internet it seems like overwatch and
blizzard are sort of doing their own
their own thing is that randy pitchford
on the phone yeah i think you're just uh
shut them up shut up just tell until
danny stop well we also have law
breakers on the horizon too oh yeah we
do you're right i wish i was
surprisingly i was surprised i had a
good time at pax east is law breakers
basically another overwatch no it's more
like well yeah
it's okay so it's closer to overwatch
than it is battleborn but it's like
unreal mixed with quake okay which so
it's a translocator with a railgun
exactly got it yeah can't wait for that
video lawbreakers what is lawbreakers uh
yeah we'll do that one next i guess
thank you so much both of you for coming
in spoilers you actually obey the law
the entire time you play that game it's
like uh battlefield hardline it's just
like show the show the shield you drive
at the speed limit and you
professionally greet other players in
the middle of the map hello
yeah looking forward to that one uh yeah
thank you so much for coming in talking
about overwatch in battleborn let us
know in the comments if you played
either or both if you got involved in
the overwatch open beta what did you
think of that and have you been enjoying
battleborn i mean overwatch in there for
a couple of weeks now so it's the
perfect time to go and pick that one up
maybe give it a go let us know your
thoughts in the comments below
mr samson we're done with you now okay
you may leave i'm out thank you so much
for coming in as ever thank you talking
about first person games we got jake
decker coming in
our geralt of rivia expert here in the
gamespot office a video game that we
love here jake how you doing i'm doing
great how are you i'm i'm pretty good we
have a show full of really good games
where i haven't even gotten to uh to
uncharted yet which both of you have
completed i believe yeah yeah all right
fair play uh okay let's jump into into
geralt mike have you complete you
completed the witcher 3 wild hunt have
you played any of blood and wine at all
no not blood and wine i played through
hearts of stone yeah beat the witcher 3
base game yes and hearts of stone was a
super good expansion pack but sort of a
fraction of the content in comparison to
what's coming out of of blood and wine
it seems uh jake how much did you play
so we played about three hours of the
expansion and there's supposedly 20 to
30. oh wow
i think i think like if you don't want
to do all of the if you don't do all the
side stuff and all the exploration it'll
probably take around 20 hours just to do
the main quest but they said yeah you
can you can take 30 hours on this thing
i'll probably take more
just because i've so invested in that
world but yeah it sounds like a good
chunk of content geez
cd project of like a problem well jake
has a problem he's beat the game
three times at least and one was on that
death march and i think he's playing it
again right now you completed witcher 3
three times yeah cause which was three
you got to do it three times right
that's that's how it was that works
work have you played final fantasy 15
yet
you are screwed no i'm gonna avoid that
one i think
so okay then you very much are an expert
of all things witchering i guess the
first question i'd ask is this new world
that they've built um how big is it and
how does it look and feel is it is it
very different or is it just like a
reskin or how did it feel to you it
feels substantive so it i i think it's
very different so you know how like uh
tamarion sort of the northern realms are
very war-torn and
you know lots of people were like taking
sides and battling it out um this one is
sort of untouched by wars they've said
multiple times
um so when you're wandering around you
don't really see like battlefields you
won't see people sort of displaced from
their homes
um it seems it's got a much lighter air
to it but um from what we played there
is
dark things brewing okay in tucson um
but yeah as for size it's about
it's about the size of no man's land
okay so it's a good size
um should be plenty to do and obviously
hearts of stone was sort of a
single player quest within the normal
world of of the witcher 3 um which did
have some side quests as well and bits
and bobs when you get out into this
world obviously there's a main quest but
is it sort of littered with question
marks around the place as well for
random side quests and encounters and
stuff yeah so we actually had when rob
and i played on the map we had all of
those already like marked okay so when
you look at it yeah there's i think in
the fact sheet they sent us there's like
90 new quests oh right um so there's
plenty of quests i mean i don't know how
long they'll be they'll probably vary in
length but um it sounds like there's
gonna be plenty to do lots of uh
locations i think there's 40 locations
too from what i read
um yeah
pretty cool um so what else is different
in terms of gameplay i know they've
added a bunch of armor and whatnot um
yeah anything substantive in that
respect like yeah so i mean the armor's
big i know they're gonna add more
witcher sets um i think the two biggest
things i took away from it was the new
mutagens um i think they said there's
around 12 new mutagens and these aren't
just like perks you know how in the main
game you kind of had uh you know you
choose perks then you assign them to a
slot and you can only assign around 12.
um but these aren't these aren't like
passive skills these are very aggressive
skills from what i saw like they showed
us one they showed us a variation of art
where geralt would have like a huge
blast radius
and enemies around him would freeze all
right um and they even told us like yeah
these are pretty overpowered like uh
this is something you're gonna do later
in the game and you can tear through
enemies does that stuff pull over into
regular witcher do you think
um so that's something i'm not entirely
sure about like i don't know if you have
to get the expansion in order to
in order in order to um use all these
mutagens
um it's hard to say um they're also
revamping the ui too so this kind of
falls in place with the with the new
character screen um where you can assign
new mutagens there's it's all redone so
it looks nice and clean i mean this is
the final chapter in the story of gelato
riviera you have to imagine maybe i mean
do you actually one more point do you
have to clarify do you have to complete
the first game to have done this or does
it work like hard to stone where you can
sort of like boot in if you don't have a
high level character or how does that
work yeah so if you if you haven't been
the witcher 3 or well you should beat
the witcher 3 if you haven't beaten the
witcher 3. um you can just start a game
right at the beginning of it so similar
what you could do in hearts of stone um
yeah so you can start right into it um
with geralt that's already you know got
equipment and he's leveled up to a
certain extent otherwise i think you
need to be level 35.
uh whether or not you have to beat the
game or not they were kind of unclear
about that but it sounds like you don't
have to but i'm pretty sure you need to
be sort of nearing the end and probably
for spoiler stuff they might want to you
might want to have completed the end i
remember that in the hearts of stone
that there was sort of certain nods to
late game stuff maybe not end stuff but
like late game stuff that they sort of
spoiled a little bit so yeah it's
similar with this i mean i even found
something i don't say exactly what it
was but it was definitely referencing
something that took place near the end
um i actually found it and the the
developer was there was like oh i don't
actually think you're supposed to find
that and that's really this demo but
yeah there you go uh you excited first
mike yeah definitely i mean after
playing hearts of stone and getting a
little bit of taste like a new expansion
and what they were trying to do with
telling these incidental side stories
that didn't really affect the
overarching plot or actually they did
they introduced a kind of a big villain
i guess and i'm not sure if he'll be in
dussan but
i loved like um
point lookout and fallout 3 because they
actually gave me a new world to explore
and i'm looking forward to far harbor
which actually now that i think of it
if like the rumored release dates are
true for both are they going to be near
each other oh really yeah because they
actually have a real estate for this
right yeah right after they put their
video up there yeah
may 31st yeah and fart harbor's not too
far off right uh let me look it up
because if those are both like
simultaneous that's gonna
force a pretty tough decision yeah
that's like a full rpg right there
that's four may 19th oh man all right
yeah so
uh yeah i'm
what is it uh blood and wine i'm really
excited for because i i love witcher 3 i
played through it i played through like
another half of a play through i don't
feel the need to go back to it right now
having a new area to explore and like he
had said the whole idea of like peace
time kind of and seeing how the war
invades this area as opposed to seeing
the aftermath is really appealing to me
i love it it kind of reminds me of
like there was a very sort of british
isles feel to i mean skellige is
literally an irish word and like scott a
scott's gaelic word and then like the
rest of it sort of felt a little bit
like england and you had the sort of the
rich people of the south of england
living in novograd and the poor people
from the north living in the south this
kind of feels like the mediterranean a
bit where they're all a little bit pump
pompous and sort of yeah well to do and
stuff like that yeah i mean you figure
because there's no war there a lot of
them are very focused on you know luxury
um and you know wine is huge in this so
you know geralt gets his own vineyard
apparently really um yeah so they showed
us a little bit of that
um but yeah so you complete a mission
and you get a key and you can go there
and apparently you can upgrade it and
make some sick wine like a home base
and dye your clothes too because
that's what you do and there's no war
i hope there's another getting drunk in
your house scene like the great one from
the witcher's three uh that's awesome uh
so i guess you know you're a big fan of
the series final point on this after
playing three hours of it were you
what was your expectation going into it
and how did you sort of feel as a fan of
the series once you've walked out of
that room so i pretty much felt that cd
projekt red delivered on almost
everything that i was hoping for at
least from what i played um there was a
new character who was from the book
which had me really excited because i
was kind of curious where he had been in
this whole lore but he shows up from
which book he's from
he's from this i think he's second and
third okay i've only read the first
three and then the short story so i'm
not entirely sure my only real concern
though is uh
the last expansion we didn't really see
tris jennifer siri dandelion and i was
like all right that's fine it's kind of
a side story but this one if we don't
see them i'm going to be
i'm going to be pretty bummed because
i've spent so much time with those
characters it's gonna be weird not to
see
siri or yen but it's cd projekt red i
have a feeling
we'll see them but might poke their
heads in somewhere uh in any case it'll
be the final time we see uh geralt of
riviera for a little while but then
again guess we can't be too sad because
then that means they're working on
cyberpunk 2077 so another game to look
forward to yeah wonderful to see i mean
that was the fantastic surprise of last
year that that game was as good as it
was um and it's wonderful to have more
expansion packs coming out it is out may
24 no 31st 31st 31st the week after the
fallout far harbor and overwatch and
overwatch which is
those are a week after doom and that's a
week
may 31st is a week before mirrors edge
really
and i better where are we a few weeks
maybe yeah right so if you haven't been
already you might want to start saving
your shekels because there's a bunch of
big video games coming up and beating
the games you haven't beaten yes exactly
i'm being the game yeah i have to do the
awful i played on xbox one for like 150
odd hours and
now i have
for which you're thrilled and like now i
in that time i built a new pc so like
i couldn't cross
bring the save over anything which is
really annoying but so wait do you have
to play like 60 hours of the witcher 3
before you get to i mean i probably i
have a character leveled up for hearts
of stone
like one i pre-built one or one you're
probably
same level recommendation so you should
be okay good to know all right let's
stop talking about witcher because we'll
just keep talking about the witcher all
day oh yeah and another game
that i guess came out this month that
might be good i don't know is uncharted
4 today it's out today well you can buy
it right now why are you watching this
they download it i pre-downloaded it
last night yeah they had that little
ticker saying it'll be unlocked in 15
minutes
then i'd go play tennis for an hour
which sucked because i wanted to play
uncharted michael hardy you've played a
lot of tennis
tennis this is good it's got i have some
complaints with it but it's overall it's
worth the experience
2017 so let's talk about it
which is what i meant to say originally
you played a lot of uncharted you
awarded it a 10 out of 10. i guess well
i've actually lost count of team out of
10 in attendance you've given 12. 12 now
there was a time where it was down to
like it was only like seven about a year
ago
yeah and then met like your solid the
witcher 3
and journey got them last year uh
uncharted four the best uncharted game
yeah definitely so it's not inside of
two was really good it's not as
groundbreaking as uncharted 2 but it is
better okay because uncharted 2 came
along and blew all our faces off what's
happening and video games can do this
right yeah and now uncharted 4 is saying
well really this is what we can do okay
it's just not as much of a surprise
right um it's it's awesome it's in so
many different aspects and it's not all
it's not just the individual quality of
it like the combat the storytelling the
writing the animation just how it looks
it's how they all kind of combine to
form something that uses all of its
aspects to tell a story that you
couldn't really tell the same way in any
other medium so explain i guess sort of
the nuts and bolts of that like what are
the things in this game which feel
you know if not groundbreaking then
better than anyone else has done within
this genre in uncharted 4. sure so you
watch a cutscene and the animations the
first off the facial animations and
animations in general are pretty much
they're it's it's the like the way that
it can express like just distrust
something that you couldn't right see on
a video game character's face most of
the time the way they do that is pretty
great and how the writing flows into
that um but also when you're just
fighting there'll be these incidental
little things that they do like
uncharted has always done this but
there's even there's points where like
certain relationships will start to
change and the dynamics will change and
like the way they address each other
when you just walk by them when you're
playing will actually kind of
react to that and you at first i was
like i think i'm looking too much into
this but then they kind of addressed
that later like oh they meant that and
there's so many ways that they use the
world itself to tell a story like rob
pointed something out to me and
something happened on the time i'm
trying very hard not to spoil anything
it sounds like i'm dumb it's because
yeah i'm being general so something
happens with these characters and then
rob noticed something in the world the
landscape itself that
like looked differently which was pretty
crazy that they did that but i don't
know jake and i both beaten it and i
know you're playing right now and it
also it flows so well it i love the
intimate personal moments between
characters just as much as the crazy
action car chases through madagascar
it's the way that they flow into one
another and kind of maintain the
momentum even when you're not fighting
and you're just kind of driving through
this countryside and hearing these two
characters talk it's it's such a great
way to tell a story in so many different
ways and it's it's really the momentum
doesn't let up the whole time i mean you
know naughty dog are a long way from
crash bandicoot in this game just when
you think about it in like a post uh
last of us world like they really are
just incredible at making stories and
i've only played the first two chapters
which i think were
maybe an hour and a half maybe long or
something in total and like i put the
controller down to hop on the bus to
come to work and was just like god damn
it this is so
brilliant i'm just enjoying every minute
of it uh jake what's been your
experience playing it where does this
sit in terms of the rest of the
uncharted like have you have you
experienced all those other games as
well and does this feel special yeah so
i played all the uncharted uncharted
games and this one's definitely my
favorite i pretty much agree with what
mike said i think the way it tells the
story has just been so fine-tuned the
way naughty dog does it has they've
basically perfected at least the sort of
storytelling they're trying to go for um
you know how gameplay cuts in gameplay
cutscene but like there are parts where
you can't even tell which is crazy um i
remember like when uncharted 2 came out
sony did that promotion like like you
can't tell if you're playing a game or
watching a movie or whatever and this
actually feels like that and the one
scene in madagascar that he kind of
mentioned a second we saw at e3 like
that's all
to look like gamepl and then you play
through it and you're like oh my god i
am actually controlling this and it's
it's breathtaking i was taken aback
because in like the past couple of
months i've become a little bit of a pc
snob again because i've upgraded my rig
and i'm like really enjoying games
whereas like oh last year i basically
just played games on xbox one and
playstation 4. um and i gotta say when i
was about maybe five minutes into this
game when i play station four sounded
like it was about to take off which
didn't matter because i was i had the
volume up pretty high but
there are times i'm playing this game
i'm like man this is running on a
goddamn playstation 4. like there's
something about naughty dog they've
always managed to like crank the most
out of uh the playstation i don't know
what it is it looks incredible yeah it's
weird um runs incredible oh yeah the
frame rate animation the vistas
themselves it's not like they're doing
one of them really well like so many
other games those like across the board
it just looks tremendous yeah i mean the
30 frames in campaign the 60 and
multiplayer both like i don't think i
saw stutter the entire campaign of the
bunch of hours i put into multiplayer i
didn't see any problems uh the way that
they actually like uh rob hanlery well a
bunch of us have been doing using the
photo mode in the game right which it's
telling of how a game looks that you
actually are encouraged you want to use
that otherwise what would be just like a
bonus aspect didn't they put that in
left behind wasn't it in the right way
or it was in sponsor when it came to ps4
they brought it it was on the last of us
and left behind yeah and we've been
taking photos and there are a couple
there's one rob got of this
old hallway and at the end there's this
there's this window open and it's
shining light on these puddles this
dilapidated place and it looks photo
realistic it's it's crazy like how the
lighting plays off of certain areas and
how
like especially in the cutscenes the
characters faces just it's the way like
there's one scene jake and i always talk
about and you can read it differently
that's like it's a very well-written
story and you can kind of look at
certain characters what they say and how
they mean it at one point a character
says like we've got a lot of ground to
cover and you're kind of thinking oh
well they just mean like the
geographically but then but then you
kind of start thinking about it like oh
or they could just like be sort of on
the way to
it's like they're talking about their
relationship kind of like there's a
bunch of different dynamics going on and
the way that the facial animations and
how it looks during the cutscenes in and
out that they actually just kind of push
that story without even using words it's
insane yeah um i guess i have a very
selfish question how long is it because
i've been only playing a couple of hours
but i already know that i don't want
this to end so
what what are we clocking in took me i
think my total save time was like 13 45
about 14 hours or so yeah um
already mine was probably about the same
i think maybe 12 hours i did in two
sittings
yeah i mean you gotta you know all that
time playing the witcher you just gotta
cram it in there somewhere you you have
to complain
three again um but yeah i think mine was
probably about 12 13 maybe the first the
first third of the games there are 22
chapters and then a fairly lengthy
epilogue right there are the first third
of the game
is kind of slow and it's in a good slow
it's in its pacing but then that's what
it feels like in a charter game and then
after that and i hear see like peter
brown sat down one sitting got to
chapter 11.
in chapters it's halfway but it starts
to get a little longer because
another thing that this game does
differently is structurally uh it opens
up a lot of its level design there are
well we saw the jeep sort of
couple weeks ago i think there are about
three areas where it's really open and
you're driving through and exploring and
then there are these it's almost like
metal gear solid five not as not as like
directly focused on stealth and combat
as metal yourself space invasion right
there are these outposts you can sneak
into tall grass climb on ledges mark
people and then you can even
just go through you can avoid them you
can just you don't even have to engage
in combat and which feeds more into this
story because the story is very much of
drake kind of coming to grips with the
fact that
he's not a good person in the first
three games yeah and they address that
really oh that's that's my favorite it's
okay cause i've spent the elephants in
the room
forever with those games because they
crafted these incredibly believable
characters but still have them in a
place where they're mowing down hundreds
of people i mean you're still fighting
this game you will kill people at
certain points
it's a third-person shooter but
the gameplay itself not only that's
what's crazy about it uh you know like
josh shearer and uh neil druckmann who
wrote this have somehow found a way to
address the problems of the first three
games of this writing whether you think
they're problems or not which i always
when i returned to the collection last
year it felt weirder like they have such
a sense of humor and they kind of after
they kill the most people but now they
actually kind of address drake's psyche
and that this is how he uses his humor
as a shield this is how like he's always
grew up
he's been a loner most of his life and
he it kind of that's why he doesn't open
up well and a lot of it he don't hate
home for me and maybe for you um
i know this is such a like stretch but i
remember like when roger ebert was
writing about martin scorsese he would
always say like his uh growing up
catholic plays a lot more into the work
than it does and they you kind of see
that here and that hit home for me i
grew up catholic and you kind of see how
that shaped him as a kid
immediately the first couple of hours
was very much like yeah and like you get
he gets older and he stops like
believing in like that's that kind of
religion but now he but he believes in
this like the eldorado exists so like
it's like it's him replacing what he
used to believe in with these new things
and they kind of addressed how he has
his characters developed the entire
series and you know the big driving
thing is um
i don't never mind i'm getting toward
spoilers that's let's play the game
because i want to and then we're doing
it we're recording yeah we're recording
a spoiler cast later and i can't wait to
get into because this is this is the
kind of game where you can
i you know like not to sound like a
pompous
jerk but you can really analyze the
stuff and look at like look deeper at it
because but not just in its writing in
like it's gameplay and how that factors
into it and how certain characters
interact in the game and how like
certain visuals look and how certain
shots are framed it's it's it's really
really good awesome but at the same time
it's just the pacing is so great that
it's it's the game is fun as hell like
in no way do i want to make it sound
like it's just this like artistic kind
of thing it's uncharted you're going to
blow things up it's you got a grappling
hook this time around it makes battles
feel really fun you can sneak past
people without fighting if you want it
gives you more choices on how to play
you can explore this time around it's
uncharted you're going to be like globe
trotting in these really cool places
yeah play this game exciting stuff play
this game you heard it you're first i'm
very fascinated by that idea of like
solving the bioshock infinite problem oh
yeah or like diving into like the sort
of spec off the line type of narrative
storytelling as well that's that's super
fascinating uh thank you both uh for
coming in and talking to us about
uncharted 4 a thief's end available now
on your playstation 4. that's it sorry
pc and xbox one owners maybe this is
worth picking up a ps4 though yeah yeah
if you don't have one
all right that's a show thank you so
much everyone who's been watching today
on twitch.tv foreign spot on
gamespot.com and of course to all our
friends listening wherever you may be on
itunes make sure to subscribe and rate
that bad boy on there of course we also
give the episode an audio on soundcloud
and all these other stitcher and all
those other things so if
whatever your poison of choice is uh
make sure uh you can pick it up there
all right we're done thank you so much
to everyone in the back for putting it
together uh rigidly on the steadicam
there give it a little nod richard
you're having a knotter having
yeah that's kind of hard on that camera
there you go there you go uh richard lee
of course mary cash eric tay and
jean-luc
seba
i'm so sorry
i got
his name's way cooler than me
mike maherty mcmahon is pretty good you
sound like an extra in the departed
mike which means i'm gonna get shot in
the face yeah probably all right sweet
speaking of stacey and laps catholics
yeah exactly i sound like a farmer from
[ __ ] donnygal yeah daddy o'dwyer well
you say things like chinwag and donkey
what does donkey use mean you said that
earlier in the show you said the donkey
years i know they're laughing back
i said the donkey years yes you heard
that i heard it i made a face aaron and
i i don't think aaron knew what it was
either i think i said something else but
it sounded like donkey ears
i said donkey ears but i don't know how
that was the thing you said you said
like disney infinity like it was in its
donkey years
you said it like i don't think i'm going
crazy
subconscious irish person in the middle
of like a leprechaun who's just throwing
these words out say 10 wags
speaking of like figuring out people's
personalities maybe you are like a
farmer at heart
yeah
all right well that's the show for this
week make sure to subscribe and we'll
see you
next donkey year take care
you